تحول الان مباشره الى هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
لمرشح الجوله الاولى للانتخابات الرئاسيه
التركيه سنان اوغان لاعلان اسم المرشح
الذي سيدعمه في الجوله الثانيه المقرره في
28 من الشهر الجاي
نحن في تحالف الاجداد نتكون من عده
من عده
زر ونحن نشكر كل ونشكر كل من شارك في هذه
اللحظه
ونشكر
[موسيقى]
على هذه النسبه قبل كل شيء
انه ساهم في هذه الانتخابات وارتفع بنسبه
المشاركه لنصف قياسيه
نواحزاب تحالف الاجداد
نشكر كل احزابها ونشكر كل
من فيها
كما
ونشكر
كل من انتخبنا سواء كان في التحالف او
غيرها
من احزاب اخرى
ولكل من يعمل فيها ولكل انصارها منذ عشر
سنوات
وهنالك امطار لنا يشاركوننا في حزبنا
نشكرهم كلهم شكرا جزيلا
والنشر ايضا
ساعتني انا شخصيا في مسيره هذه
اننا في مكان اخر واطم اننا في دوله اخرى
نشكر كل من ساهم
في ارتفاع الكلاب
من مواطنين
نشكر كل من دعمنا
من خلال التوقيح على انتخابي وترشح روحي
اشكر 110 الاف 110,000 مواطن وقعوا على
ترشيحي
كل من داعمني ماديا وساهم في
دعمي وساهم في مساعدتي ونشكر
والدعاه ملصقاتنا وكل من علق صورتي وعلق
على سيارته وعلى منزلته ومنزله وعلى
محل تجاريه
اشكر كل الحشود التي احتجت من ذاتها من
نفسها
وخاصه اشكر شبابنا الذين كانوا كفل العالم
كل خطوه من خطوه هؤلاء الشباب اشكركم شكرا
جزيلا
نشكر كل وسائل الاعلام القليله التي
اخرجتنا على الاعلام رغم ان الكثير من
وسائل الاعلام لم تجعلنا نخرج
وعلما ان كثير من وسائل الاعلام
نشرت حولنا اخبارا سلبيه الكثير من وسائل
الاعلام الاجتماعي
اخبارا ملفقه الكثير من
لكننا كنا واقفين على اقدامنا
قبل ثلاث سنوات تقريبا
قلنا بان على
القومين الاتراك ان يكون لهم مرشح في
الرئته
وفي ثلاثه سنوات
وكثير من الاشخاص
استشهدوا من اجل دعم سنان الاوغانم بصفه
شخصيه قوميه
قلنا
انه لو انه واحد قومي خرج مرشحا للرئاسه
لكنا سحبنا
وقلنا باننا سندعم اي قومي ينتخب لنفسه
لكن لم يخرج اي شخص قومي
ننتخبه
في نهايه المشوار
تحالف الاجداد خرج
واعلنني مرشحا في الحادي عشر من مايور
وعملت مرشحا لتحالف الاجداد
للاسف الشديد
هنالك الكثير ممن يستغربون
حصولنا على 5.2 رغم اننا لم نصبح مرشحين
هو في الشهر الاخير
للاسف الشديد هؤلاء لماذا يستغلون
على الاقل
نحن
صغنا
برنامجنا سنوات هذا الموضوع خلال الشهر
الاخير لا تقلل من شاننا لا تقلل من شان
القوميين في تركيا انصحكم انصح هؤلاء
الذين يستخرج ان يتابعونا
ومنذ الحادي عشر من مايو
عفوا
ونحن نعمل بقوه
كان المفترض ان ناخذ في الشروط العاديه
اصواتا ما بين الى 10%
الكل يتحدث والكل يعرف وكل وسائل الاعلام
كانت تعلم والشركات استطلاع الراي كانت
تعرف بان هنالك قاعده قويه تخرج من الاسفل
من القاعده تقول بان القوميين سيرتفعون
لكن هنالك كان
وتوما عنيفا ضدنا ضد التيت اوميغا
وحاولوا قتل اعتبارنا وحاولوا اخفاء قومنا
اريد ان اقول لكم
[موسيقى]
هذا الهجوم الذي يطبق علينا هذا الهجوم
الجماعي الذي طبق علينا هجوم قوي جدا
واختلط جدا
وكذلك من
من جهه الخدمات الاخرى الاعلاميه وغيرها
ولكن رغم ذلك كافحنا وبذلنا جهودا كبيرا
من اجل ذلك
ونحن طبعا كان لدينا الكثير من المتطوعين
في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ودعمونا واستطعنا من خلال ذلك ان نكسر
الاسنان
ونحن طبعا اداره
هذا البلد والتقدم في
خطوه بخطوه من اجل اداره هذا البلد ونحن
باذن الله تعالى سنقوم بهذا الامر وهذا هو
الذي نهدفهم
طبعا من خلال عناوين في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي نحن كنا قد اعلنا عنها مسبقا
ولدينا بعض الاهداف التي نريد ان نعلن
عنها عندما نقوم بتقييمها وهذه تحولت الى
اهم جدول في البلد
نحن
قمنا
بمحاوله
دفعونا الى
ان نكون خارج هذا السباق الرئاسي بين
المرشحين وكانت هناك محاوله كبيره ولكن
رغم ذلك فخذنا في الانتخابات
واستطعنا ان نحصل على نسبه
في الانتخابات والان
بدانا في العمل للجوله الثانيه واصبحنا من
اهم
العوامل ومن اهم لاعبي الادوار في هذه
الجوله الثانيه قبيل الجوله الثانيه
طبعا فيما يتعلق باللاجئين قمنا بتوعيه
كافيه
وكانت لدينا كثير من المساهمات في هذا
الموضوع وكذلك فيما يتعلق بمكافحه
التنظيمات الارهابيه كان لدينا دور كبير
وفي السياسه التركيه منعناهم من ان ياخذوا
السياسه التركيه كاثير بايديهم وقمنا
بتوعيه شامله في كل هذه الامور
طبعا السياسه التي اتبعناها كانت جيده جدا
وحصلنا على دعم الشعب التركي وحصل توعيه
جيده للمواطنين ولناخبين
احمد جواد الشاعر التركي
يشير الى نسيم عندما يسالون عن الوطن فانا
استطيع ان اشرح لهم ما هو الوطن وانا ابدا
لن اقوم بخيانه الوطن وفي هذه الانتخابات
هذه هي اشياء السياسه التي قمنا باتباعها
ونجحنا في ذلك
حاليا
اصبح صوت التركي يصبح ويصرخ
الحقيقه نتيجه طبعا الانتخابات في الجوله
الثانيه فاعتقد هناك رسائل اعطتها يجب ان
ننتبه لها في الرابعه عشر
يوجد لها حل عاجل
تركيا
يجب
المتواجدين في تركيا من ناحيه الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه
وغيرها من الامور في كثير من المجالات
فاصبحوا
تكلفه يكلفون على تركيا يكلفون على تركيا
فلذلك يجب اعاده ترحيلهم وفيما يتعلق
بالزلزال ايضا هو
الزلزال هو امر مهم جدا متعلق بالامن
القومي
قد تحدث مشاكل كبيره اقتصاديه وغيرها في
المجالات فلذلك يجب ان نقوم
بايجاد
بتاسيس وزاره فيما يتعلق بالزلزال وزاره
الزلزال
وهناكريات الداخليه خارجيه ايضا وهذه تؤثر
بشكل او باخر على الاقتصاد نعم اقتصاد
البلد وعلى المواطن المواطنين فلذلك يجب
ان يكون هناك
قرارات سريعه وحلول نعم سريعا من اجل
تحسين الوضع الاقتصادي
الرابع الموضوع الرابع هو ان يكون هناك
مكافحه مستقره تجاهها كل الجماعات
والتنظيمات الارهابيه ويجب ان تكون هذه
بتوفير كل الامكانات المتاحه من اجل
مكافحه
الارهاب
وهذا يجب ان يكون مضمون
فيجب ان يتم
تنظيف كل الجماعات او التنظيمات الارهابيه
والذراعها في السياسه التركيه ويجب
ابعادها تماما عن السياسه التركيه
وطبعا
في النقطه التي وصلنا اليها اعتقد نحن
وصلنا الى الهدف الذي كنا نريده وهو
ابعاده الجماعات الارهابيه واذرعها من
السياسه التركيه
مهمه جدا قدر المستطاع مستطاع من اجل
خدمه
المواطنين وخدمه هذا البلد وفيه فتره
الحمله الانتخابيه التي قمنا بها فكانت
هناك ردود فعل من المواطنين ومن الناخبين
وكانت ايجابيه وكان بشكل عام في اجواء
ايجابيه
حسب ما الاحظه
ان الصناعه الدفاعيه طبعا يجب ان تستمر
والصناعه الدفاعيه الوطنيه يجب ان تكون
مستمره وكذلك يجب الدعم كل المشاريع
الوطنيه
هذا مهم جدا من اجل تركيا ويجب على الجميع
ان يضع يده تحت الحجر من اجل ذلك
يجب تقويه العلاقات مع الدول التركيه ايضا
والسياسات المتعلقه
بالفائده يجب ان نعيد النظر فيها مره اخرى
ويجب التخلص من الفائده والتضخم ويجب ان
نقوم بايجاد حلول وبقرارات سريعه من اجل
تحسين الوضع الاقتصادي
الرئيس الذي سيتم انتخابه يجب ان يكون
بتوافق في حاله توافق ووئام مع البرلمان
من اجل اتخاذ قرارات لخدمه ولصالح هذا
البلد
ان
المعارضه لم تنجح في هذا السباق الرئاسي
ولم تستطيع ان تقنعنا ولم تستطيع ان تحصل
على اغلبيه في البرلمان
نعم هناك مفاوضات نحن لم نقم بها ولم نقوم
بطلب اي مناصب فمقاربتنا تماما كانت مبنيه
على مصالح البلاد وعلى مصالحنا القوميه
والوطنيه
دوله تركيا جمهوريه تركيا من اجل وحدتها
وبقائها ومستقبلها هذا هو هذا هو المهم
بالنسبه لسياساتنا
طبعا نحن نهدف الى المكاسب التي حصلت
عليها جمهوريتنا في ضمن هذه
القيم والمبادئ نعم نتج قرارنا
وكل الجماعات
الارهابيه كل
فسيكون هناك مكافحه مستمره تجاه هذه
الجماعات الارهابيه
ايضا فيما يتعلق
اللاجئين فيجب ان يكون هناك جدول زمني
ويجب ان يتم البدء بهذا الجدول الزمني من
اجل اعاده اللاجئين الى دوالهم بشكل امن
وكل الظروف والشروط يجب ان يتم تطبيقها من
اجل ذلك ويجب ان يتم اتخاذ كل التدابير
اللازمه باعلى مستواها من اجل منع دخول
المهاجرين الى اراضينا ويجب ان يتم اتخاذ
كل التدابير عبر في الحدود
ونحن نرى هذه
كله
مره اخرى
من اجل ان يكون هناك توحد للقوه
فاعتقد يجب ان يكون هناك تجمع للدول
التركيه تحتم مظله واحده ويجب دعم هذا
المشروع
الانتخابات في الجوله الثانيه لها اهميه
بالغه
لذلك اعطيت فاكهه
قمنا باستشارات موسعه مع كل الرؤساء في
الحزب والمسؤولين ومع اصحاب القرار في هذا
التحالف تحالف الاجداد
واعلنا باننا سنقول
قمنا بلقاءات مع
المرشحين مرشح تحالف الجمهور ورشح تحالف
امه وبعد
اللقاءات وبعد التواصل معهم قمنا بمذاكره
وتشاور
الموضوع
ان نقدم اي طلب فنحن قمنا بالدفاع عن
مبادئنا وعن قيمنا وعن الخطوط الحمراء
التي قمنا باتخاذ القرار حولها
كانت كل هذه اللقاءات مبنيه على الاحترام
وعلى التفاهم المشترك
نتيجه كل هذه القرارات
ان ندعم السيد رئيس الجمهوريه
السيد رجب طيب اردوغان رئيس التحالف
الجمهوري
وعندما اتخذنا هذا القرار قررنا بان اننا
سنقف معه وسندعمه
ونحن امنا ونؤمن بان هذا القرار هو القرار
الصحيح لخدمه البلد
لم نقوم
فنتمنى ان يكون هذا القرار وسيله للخير
لنا جميعا واقدم لكم التحيه والاحترام
هذا النصر الذي تلوته هو المعتبر
وسيتم توزيع هذا النص على الاخوه الصحفيين
ولن استقبل اي سؤال واشكركم وشكرا جزيلا
لكم